exclusively from people.com's real life  love story  um there is a miraculous story and of  course when I saw this I went straight  to a 51st dates place and said we have  to talk about this on the news this is  real Andrew and Christy McKenzie  recently married after a devastating  accident temporarily wiped out Andrew's  memory now my favorite part of this  story is that Christy insisted they stay  in the same recovery room she told  nurses if you let us be together he will  get better and he did it's real life  that is real life 51st stage  and all you can say about that you know  people say love conquers all love wins  that's certainly a great great story